You have something
to give back.
All lives have equal value, but
we don't treat them that way.
Just because of where
you're born in the world
has a determining
effect of whether you're
going to survive to
your fifth birthday.
That is not equal opportunity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Over 20 years, I've
learned in philanthropy
there are so many different
ways to give: time, money,
expertise, your voice.
I'm not going to teach
you which organizations
to focus on-- that's very
personal, and that's up to you.
But I will be offering
you a framework and a way
to think about giving.
Go to where your passion is.
What is the thing
that you wake up
thinking about in the morning?
You say, "Ah!
Why is this happening
in my community?
I don't believe in this!"
You do philanthropy
because you believe deeply
that you want to leave
the world a better place.
[MUSIC PLAYING]